let's do a little debate fact-check when
it comes to the third and final
presidential debate we have now our lie
totals we did this after the first
debate I think we did it after the
second debate as well Donald Trump told
37 lies in Wednesday's last presidential
debate Hillary Clinton told four I'll
just go through a few of the Trump ones
because there were 37 we don't have two
hours to dig into all of them I'll
quickly tell you Hillary Clinton's four
lies first okay number one Hillary
Clinton falsely said she will not add a
penny to the debt her tax plan actually
will add two hundred billion to the debt
according to the committee for
responsible federal budget number two
Hillary Clinton falsely said that at the
end of ex-president Bill Clinton's
administration we were actually on the
path to eliminating the national debt
that's not really true I mean it totaled
the the it totaled three point four
trillion at the end of the year 2000 and
that was up from three trillion in 1992
I guess you could kind of say well by
the end there was a surplus so if the
surplus remained indefinitely it would
start to chip away at the national debt
but it's it's not exactly what I could
would call a perfectly representative
statement number three live from Hillary
Clinton at the last debate
she said Mosel is on the border of Syria
Mosul is more than a hundred kilometers
from the border so I guess it's not
really on the border and number four
hillary clinton falsely said that DC vs.
Heller was about gun rights this is sort
of a grain of truth but it's kind of
misleading the case was about the DC
handgun ban and it's not exactly about
gun rights per se but as you can see the
for Hillary Clinton lies there
politician lies to the extent that there
lies at all and they all hold a grain of
truth now for comparison in contrast
let's go through just a couple of Donald
Trump's lies from the debate for example
Donald Trump fall
we said Justice Ginsburg made some very
inappropriate statements toward me and
toward a tremendous number of people
many many millions of people that I
represent Ruth Bader Ginsburg did
criticize Donald Trump she did not slamm
millions and millions of Trump
supporters any Trump supporters at all
sort of a weird thing for Trump to say
not true Donald Trump said and he said
this many times ice last week endorsed
me ice of course is immigrations and
customs enforcement they did not endorse
Donald Trump there is a union of ice
employees which endorsed Donald Trump
it was also three weeks ago not last
week Trump keeps talking about how ice
has endorsed him iced ice is a
government agency which has not endorsed
Donald Trump they've not endorsed
anybody it's just a lie Donald Trump
said Hillary Clinton wanted the wall and
that she fought for the wall around the
year 2006 that's not true it's just not
true Hillary Clinton did vote for a
barrier which was short fencing across a
very specific space of the us-mexico
border to suggest that Hillary Clinton
wanted this 35 foot high concrete
barrier that Trump is talking about
going across the entire us-mexico border
it is just not true I'll just pick a
couple of others because again there's
just so many Trump lies we can't go
through them all Trump falsely said of
Syrian refugees they have no idea where
they come from this one is really bad
the United States has a very rigorous
vetting system for refugees and for
people coming from other countries and
to say that we don't know where people
are coming from is absolutely and
patently untrue Trump keeps repeating it
but it's just not true
I mentioned this in our post debate
coverage yesterday Donald Trump said
that we have no idea who hacked the
Democratic officials White House
officials US intelligence officials
independent experts have all concluded
that Russia is responsible but Trump
continuing to pretend like we just don't
know who did it
on taxes Donald Trump said that Hillary
Clinton's plan is going to raise and
even double your taxes I don't know who
Trump is talking to but the Clinton plan
has been analyzed in detail it will only
raise taxes on the highest earners the
Tax Policy Center said that most
residents below the one percent the top
one percent will actually receive minor
tax cuts it's a lie it is not true it's
the monster bleah untrue Trump falsely
said about Aleppo it has fallen from any
standpoint that's not true
the city of Aleppo in Syria has not
fallen it is factually incorrect Trump
said that it was wrong when Hillary
Clinton said he mimicked and mocked a
reporter with a disability listen it's
on video it's very clear that Donald
Trump mocked the guy whether or not
Trump mock the guy for his disability I
guess some people could deny that
Trump's weird thing was was was
something other than mocking the guy
maybe it was a coincidence
but he was clearly mocking the guy as an
individual and you'd be the judge of
whether he was mocking him for having a
disability I think it's obviously yes
and then lastly Trump falsely said wrong
to Hillary Clinton's claim that Trump
supported the invasion of Iraq after the
invasion Donald Trump retroactively Lee
has said a thousand ten thousand times
that he was always against it but his
pre invasion statements including one on
the Howard Stern Show were much more
positive about going into Iraq the
question is always the same one about
the Trump lies does it matter at this
point I can unequivocally say no the
Trump supporters whatever percentage of
them were deplorable whatever percentage
of them in a poll said that they believe
black people are inherently lazier by
virtue of being black whatever
percentage said that they believe yeah
Trump is right that we should ban
Muslims forget about all that at this
point there is no doubt that the hard
core trumpets or trumpeter call them
what you want does not care about
fact-checking Donald Trump does not care
about what Donald Trump does during the
Bates does not care about what it is
that Donald Trump says to Hillary
Clinton saying she's a very nasty woman
as he said during the debate last night
and and has been talked about
extensively they do not care we are two
and a half weeks out from this election
they despise Hillary Clinton by and
large they are coalesced by this
nativist xenophobic rhetoric Trump being
wrong about Aleppo is not going to
convince anybody that is already
committed to Trump to vote for somebody
else at this point you and I can keep
talking about it we'll keep talking
about it on the show for the two and a
half weeks that remain because it is
important to know what the truth is but
the Trump supporters they don't care
about lies at this point I think that's
very clear we have a fantastic program
for you today we have a great interview
coming up one of my favorite interviews
that I did with George Lakoff about
framing and language and how Republicans
have done really well when it comes to
framing and language around politics
we're also going to take live calls and
I will also be answering three audience
questions at the end of the show I'm in
Las Vegas Nevada for the mass torts made
perfect conference which wraps up today
I'm so thrilled you're joining me on
this Friday I've talked about how people
of all ages but particularly Millennials
are owning cars less and participating
more in the sharing economy and one of
the more popular options is Zipcar which
gets you a car when you want it when you
need it they offer all sorts of cars
SUVs hybrids whatever you need it
includes insurance and it includes gas
you just pay for the time that you
actually use the car and you can reserve
the car online from your smartphone over
the phone then you unlock it with your
zip card each car share member reduces
their personal co2 emissions by between
1100 and 1600 pounds per year for our
audience
Zipcar is offering $25 a free driving
credit if you sign up at join Zipcar
comm slash david support our show reduce
your carbon emissions and you're
spending on car
sign up at join Zipcar comm slash David